look ult are a hugely important part of
valerian whether you're on a eco or full
buy a single old can completely turn the
tide of a match i don't know how they
would go about it maybe an all towards
heaven oh the sky alt's coming out
paranoid is gonna have to be wasted on
this
oh no he gets the triple off the rocket
is the fourth kill he's welcome
but not all ultimates are created equal
some of them suck while others are
completely busted that's why today we
wanted to rank the most frustrating alts
in the game but before we get into it i
gotta remind you as always hit the like
and subscribe button as well as to ring
that notification bell once you're ready
buckle up because today we are counting
down the top 10 [ __ ] alts and
valerian
kicking off our list we have every
duelist player's best friend sage
leaving it down to loki a one versus two
but a res available as we said earlier
he's going to slow it he's gonna pop
that rez but he needs to cover that
player as they come back online the
swing together scream does it flash is
there back six hp remaining he's hunting
down and he gets it done that is the map
win for vitality with a defuse it is 13
to 11. she's the og support agent thanks
to her ability to delay pushes and block
off choke points that's all mostly fair
but her ult is insane resurrection
allows sage to bring one of her
teammates back from the dead which means
you might have to kill six opponents
just to win a single round killing
someone only to watch as they get rezzed
and kill you in return is an absolute
tilter
oh
no
oh no
you could do that too
oh
i was like i'm [ __ ] dead
coming in at our number nine spot we
have the german genius killjoy well now
the rest of sentinels they all they all
have to back out over towards that a
site bbg they're all here they're
waiting out for a couple of smokes that
jet smoke is going to take just a little
bit to dissipate but they're still
fighting oh my they're detained all
three are you kidding me
so many detainments off of just one go
no br is able to get four kiljoy's alt
lockdown gives players 13 seconds to get
the hell out of its aoe or else they get
slowed and can't shoot their guns use
their abilities or basically do anything
at all for eight seconds
essentially if you get detained you're
dead complexity still trying to hold the
main doors and they've done well getting
some opening trades lockdown's gonna be
here fully they're trying to get the
resurrection off and he gets detained
now from the flank it's agm gets one
mana also still stuck with both hands
questioning what just happened and the
defuse will be there with .06
holy complexity and before you say
there's counter play the best way to
beat a killjoy old is to blow one of
your own teammates old to destroy it
sure you can stop it with utility if
you're a line-up larry but for most of
us that's just not realistic making
lockdown an absolute nightmare to deal
with
oh
frankie you almost got the third
wait
oh my god
sliding into our number eight spot we
have neon oh my god you're so [ __ ]
fast right now oh my god
since her release at the start of
episode 4 neon has been terrorizing
players with her incredibly fast
movement speed but when combined with
her ultimate things really start to get
[ __ ] overdrive allows her to shoot
beams of lightning with high movement
accuracy and some insanely high dps i
promise i'm not making this [ __ ] up
getting obliterated by palpatine's
daughter feels
awful
i don't know i'm trying a thing they're
going to be coming
no way dude oh my god oh my god dude
shocking his way into the number seven
spot we have sova's giant stupid laser
around as the spike goes down you see
the dart is giving red car away hunters
fury a little dance around though
really no need oh
what on earth was that
fish in a barrel saucy gets the last
chronicles gonna have to go absolutely
ballistic and he's not gonna get the
chance the ace for saucy the seventh
round for brazil so his ult has a
massive radius and deals 80 damage each
time it touches you if you don't take
your knife out and dodge it in time then
chances are you're
and if that wasn't enough his alt
reveals enemies through smokes and walls
just like the rest of his kit it can
also be used to destroy killjoy's
lockdown completely shut down sight hits
or prevent retakes it literally does
everything which is why sova is played
on nearly every map
bro
[Music]
strolling into number six is daddy
chamber and his game breaking old
spike planted
what do you want
oh pop off baby
oh my god
is a free operator yeah you heard that
correctly he gets a gun that is normally
4 700 credits for free every four to
five rounds as long as he's not asleep
at his keyboard
but guess what chamber's old is actually
better than the actual operator it
scopes faster has a higher rate of fire
and leaves a slow field behind when you
kill an enemy with it setting up some
easy multi-frags rossi from the corner
after truck trying to push tom out of
this position but he stayed alive so
successfully with their own utility now
a corner that's going to be good for a
lot go we're down the corner though for
three off the tour still two more shots
to play off of the navy catches neon on
the boost from what was going to be a
show-stopper play and then the ace
wardell you give him a free sniper he
will make you pay
oh that's balanced by the way perfectly
balanced this whole thing should be
stunning his way into the halfway point
on our list is breach
okay don't play it to me
off your
and her grenades and her rockets and
this guy's like boom stun boom stun boom
i think we can all agree that playing
against a good breach player sucks
you're constantly getting flashed
stunned and zoned away from certain
parts of the map but the icing on the
shitty cake is breech's rolling thunder
getting hit by a breach alt is usually
game over you get knocked back seven
meters and concussed for six whole
seconds during this time your rate of
fire is lowered significantly and if
you're using a scoped weapon like a
marshal or operator then you have to
resort to no scoping your opponent which
invalorant is notoriously difficult
flying into our number four spot is jet
it was only a matter of time before we
mentioned jet on this list and i think
it's pretty obvious why she's here sick
pulls away all of that heat but contends
really capitalized off of it yes he can
yes he can tens with a third so clean
off of this blade start but he's even
gonna find the fourth this shouldn't be
a surprise jets blade storm is one of
the most frustrating things in the
entire game every seven alt points she
gets a free ak with no movement penalty
jet can jump dash and hover while
popping heads and the knives reset on
every kill
i'll take it out in the corner
she can't spam you with right clicks
anymore but bladestorm is still one of
the most [ __ ] alts in the game
defensive toxic screen diagonally moving
across and oh my goodness the shots from
neon
exquisite now back up top he wants more
oh my give it to him that's the spike
down plus three tsm members
at number three we have viper's pit the
only olds in the game that can shut down
an entire sight and leave you gasping
for air dirk is up there as well
dueling blades
jerker goes up oh durkin
gets the best of zeta and the best of
leaf
as he's looking for more vanity and his
specter all that's left he shows up just
a bit late the party's about over mate
it's just getting started no no no
party's over yep yep when a viper lays
down her ult you have two options you
can either spray through and hope to
catch her through the smoke or enter it
and watch your health slowly drain down
to one the longer you're in it the more
dangerous things become and if an enemy
catches you first then you're likely
getting one shot i've got a frenzy in a
classic wait
no way nats has made a tiny pocket to
sit inside hooker here
too
[Applause]
[Music]
could not care less but there's nats in
the little cubby and nobody puts that to
the corner because look at him three
good kills and the rifles everything
every small margin that envy wanted to
use got removed working your way through
her ult is basically just asking to die
unless you have the proper utility to
help locate viper then i suggest
avoiding it at all costs
blastpacking our way into our runner-up
spot is reyes
gotta wait up for that opportunity
actually oh no that's actually happening
no way seven come on he didn't need to
do that rey's showstopper has been one
of the most annoying ultimates in the
entire game since valerian's release and
despite some nerfs to the damage ratios
it's still pretty busted what do you do
here tell me how you counter this you're
rushing b site okay
and you guys are getting onto the site
and this guy is in the back of the site
with a rocket launcher just waiting for
you guys to hit or commit to something
then he double jumps out of the back of
the site and shoves a rocket down at
least one person's throat what does that
one person do about it she gets a free
rocket launcher that can take out entire
groups of enemies sure some players
don't find as much value with it as
others but for most of us dying to a
nearly unavoidable rocket feels pretty
awful i don't know deep smokes are
closed deep or close i don't know
actually not
three of us man not two but three
in the number one spot on our list we
have k.o
that one
one left on it right
with one click of a button ko's null
command can suppress all enemy utility
within a massive radius yeah you heard
me all of it for an entire 12 seconds ko
turns valerie into counter-strike no
abilities just guns kayla's ult also
turns him into a [ __ ] fortnite
character because he can be revived by
another teammate if you don't confirm
the kill after taking him down while
downed he continues to send out his
suppression pulses so taking out his
extra 850 health before he comes back to
piss you off again is even harder
alt increases his rate of fire just like
reyna's old or brimstone's stim beacon
sure it's unique but it absolutely sucks
to play against
well folks that's our list so what
valerian content do you want to see next
let us know down in the comment section
below take care and i'll see you in the
next one
you guys definitely did this wait he's
on there
dude it's bogged down because of the
suppress i can't understand dude this
game is actually the most buggy game
i've ever played
what the [ __ ] is that